less than four years we've cut this  state's homicide rate nearly in half  is affordable police chase that's going  on  we'll keep going into the future they  stood in very  that me  hi miss juice she go away where Elsa  excuse me I'm late for my flight I got  my kid waiting in the lobby he getting  getting the cart not today  yeah hi number two up front was it him  I'm sure of it they told me I was an  incredible witness he promised swift  justice for Vivian Hill and for a family  sorry about Sofia what do you need just  a few names we don't do this anymore  Stanley they killed her for nothing you  think you'd go back to your old life I  have to  you either gotta kill them all around  I'm not running  fighting these guys find their families  and kill them  you're supposed to count the three is  that right  everybody stay down  is why I am remember  both first and forgotten and reserved  that these shootings are not random acts  of violence